an equilibrium constant has one value
for a particular reaction at a certain
temperature for example for this
reaction we have oxalic acid turning
into two h plus ions and the oxalate
anion the equilibrium constant kc for
this reaction is equal to 3.8 times 10
to the negative 6 at 25 degrees celsius
however the value of the equilibrium
constant changes if we change how we
write the balanced equation for example
let's reverse everything so instead of
having oxalic acid on the reactant side
let's have it on the product side and
instead of having h plus ions in the
product side and oxalate on the product
side let's put them on the reactant side
since we've reversed the reaction
there's a new equilibrium constant so
we're going to write kc for the reverse
reaction is equal to and to figure out
the value for the new equilibrium
constant since we reversed everything we
take the inverse of the original
equilibrium constant
so to find the new kc value we take 1
over the original equilibrium constant
of 3.8
times
10 to the negative 6.
and this is equal to 2.6
times 10 to the fifth also at 25 degrees
celsius
let's look at another example of how
changing how we write the equation
changes the value for the equilibrium
constant
we start by looking at the ionization of
hydrofluoric acid turning into an h plus
ion and a fluoride anion the kc value
for this reaction is equal to 6.8 times
10 to the negative fourth at 25 degrees
celsius
this time we're going to multiply
everything through by a factor of two so
it would be two hf
turning into two h plus plus two f minus
our goal is to find the value for the
new equilibrium constant kc and since we
multiplied everything through by a
factor of 2 we're going to take the old
equilibrium constant and we're going to
raise it to the second power so this is
kc is equal to
6.8
times 10 to the negative fourth and
we're going to square that
so this is equal to 4.6
times 10 to the negative seventh at 25
degrees celsius
so since we multiplied through by a
factor of two we raised the equilibrium
constant to the second power if we had
multiplied through by a factor of three
we would have raised the old equilibrium
constant to the third power
let's use the two reactions we've just
looked at here so we have oxalic acid
turning into h plus and oxalate and the
other one we looked at was hydrofluoric
acid ionizing to turn into h plus and f
minus let's use those two reactions to
calculate the equilibrium constant for a
third reaction and this third reaction
shows oxalate reacting with hydrofluoric
acid to form oxalic acid
and the fluoride anion
our first step is to get these first two
reactions to look more like the third
reaction for example we have oxalic acid
on the reactant side
in the first reaction here and oxalic
acid is on the product side for the
third reaction also notice oxalate is on
the product side for the first and over
here for the third it's on the reactant
side so we need to reverse the first
reaction to make it look more like the
third one here we have that reaction
reversed and since we reversed the
reaction we would have to take
the inverse of the equilibrium constant
which we did in the earlier example so
let's go ahead and cross out this first
one here because we're not going to need
it anymore
and let's move on to our next reaction
and try to make it look more like the
third one so here we have hydrofluoric
acid turning into h plus and f minus
and for our third reaction we have
hydrofluoric acid on the reactant side
but notice there's a coefficient of two
in the balanced equation and we have
only a one in how we have it written so
we need we need to multiply everything
through by a factor of two to give us
two hf and two h plus and two f minus
and since we multiplied everything
through by a factor of two we would need
to square the equilibrium constant for
the original reaction and once again
this is from our previous example so we
already know that equilibrium constant
value
next let's add these two reactions
together and make sure they give us the
third reaction
so we have all of our reactants on one
side
and we have all of our products on the
other side here
and we look for things that are the same
on both the reactants and the product
side well there's two h plus on the left
and there's two h plus on the right so
that would cancel out
and now
notice that we would have oxalate
plus two hf
going to oxalic acid plus two f minus
so adding our two reactions together
does give us our third reaction
once we've confirmed that adding our two
reactions together gives us our third
reaction we can use the equilibrium
constants for the first two reactions to
figure out the equilibrium constant for
the third so the equilibrium constant
for this first reaction we're going to
call k1 for the second reaction we're
going to call take k2 and the
equilibrium constant that we're trying
to find for the third reaction we'll
call kc
to find the equilibrium constant for the
third reaction kc we need to multiply
the equilibrium constants for the first
two reactions together so kc is equal to
k1
times
k2
we've already calculated the value for
k1 from an earlier example it was 2.6
times 10 to the fifth and we also
calculated k2 and it was 4.6 times 10 to
the negative 7. so to find kc the
equilibrium constant for the third
reaction we simply multiply those two
together and we get that kc is equal to
.12 at 25 degrees celsius
so whenever you add reactions together
to get a new reaction to find the
equilibrium constant for the new
reaction you simply need to multiply the
equilibrium constants of the reactions
that you added together